we are now exactly one month away from
the start of these games in beijing like
the last time the country hosted the
organization the venues the staffing
will likely go without a hitch china had
impressed the world with its work on the
summer olympic games back in 2008 which
had rolled out spectacularly if anything
this will run even better
dw's clifford coonan joins us now in the
studio clifford
you were based in beijing during the
olympic games last time in 2008 as was i
so much has changed since then what kind
of country was china then and where does
it stand today
i think what's interesting is first of
all china hasn't actually changed that
much in the interim and what you have is
a lot more of china it's now the world's
third biggest economy it's become much
more of a player internationally but in
terms of how the country has run it
hasn't changed that much with the
exception that we see this huge focus
now on xi jinping
and these are very much going to be the
xi jinping olympics i think and what's
also changed i think is how the world
views china back in 2008 you'll remember
um everyone was looking at china with a
certain amount of hope um expectation
that maybe uh that increased wealth and
power would lead to a democratization or
whatever in china and i think most of
those ideas about engaging with china as
a way of driving change have largely
been um swept aside now by the by the
way the
xi jinping has imposed a very strict
rule there and the country is trying to
aim for a zero covet policy how is that
impacting the games well this is very
interesting because it could mean
there's no spectators at the games for
one um i saw today there's rules that
cheering isn't allowed um that you can
only applaud yeah you can't expel too
much
too much too many
yeah and so in some ways the games will
look a little bit like the national
people's congress with everyone
applauding but um i think the zero
covert policy i mean it's been very
successful so far in containing in
containing um covert but um how that's
going to how that's going to work in
terms of um
in terms of an international event like
the olympics is very open now i want to
pivot to human rights i mean activists
including those from the persecuted
uyghur and tibetan minority groups and
also of course people who care about
hong kong have called for a boycott of
the games sports and politics uh forever
there is a debate about whether you can
divorce the two uh i want to run at two
voices the first one is from the
international olympic committee
president thomas bach have a listen we
are not
a super world government
you know where uh the ioc could uh
solve or even address
uh issues uh
for uh
uh which
uh no not a u.n security council no
uh no g7 no g20
has a solution ironically that is the
same kind of rhetoric that people from
china always tell me when i bring up the
fact that 2 million uighurs are in
charging camps when they talk about
tibetans having their lands occupied by
china all they say is it's complicated
well clifford is it complicated there
have been a few diplomatic boycotts for
example what's the latest and does china
even care about this
well i think what's interesting i mean
in 2008 people were calling for a
boycott as well we had a very harsh
crackdown on tibetans in march of 2008
as you recall
but people people didn't seem to really
take it seriously i think people know a
lot more about china now and how they
view china has changed whether china
cares about it i still think that it
wants the olympics to be a success and
it's very important for china's
international image that the olympics
should be a success so i think they
definitely do care about it
one thing that i'm trying to
think about is context historical
context though when have the games been
boycotted um and when have people talked
about it and decided against it
boycotts are an interesting one a lot
some people say they just don't work at
all and some people say they can
actually make things happen i mean we
saw that the boycott of south africa
ultimately led to apartheid um
you know the end of apartheid um and by
isolating south africa that way um with
uh china because of its international
power um boycotting is very difficult
because china holds a lot of the
economic
power so people are loath to to go for a
full boycott i think boycotts can be
effective definitely and indeed china
boycotted the 1980 olympics uh in moscow
at the u.s led boycott so you know
anything they say about not politicizing
the olympics you know it's clearly just
a question of which olympics that's very
interesting it is right and and i think
um and china hasn't been in the olympics
that long as well it's only 1984 that
they first competed in any sort of
significant way so um but whether this
uh whether a boycott i think a
diplomatic boycott is what we're
probably going to see but people can't
just ignore the issue anymore i think
that's the big change between now and
back then is that um
you know
we know now what china is doing in in
xinjiang and in tibet and so if you
compete in the olympics you go there
with that understanding and i think
that's the biggest change
clifford kunin we're gonna have to get
you back in for a post-mortem after the
games thanks so much for joining us